on a special edition of the dish this
morning what may be the most
sought-after dinner reservation in the
country right now and it's in a small
one-room restaurant in rural Maine run
by a single mom and her mother Jeff Glor
paid them a visit I don't know what's
going on out here
it's wild but I have to tell you I just
think you're all a part of this Erin
French starts accepting reservations for
the lost kitchen every year at midnight
on April 1st the entire season is booked
within hours coming all this way and for
working so hard to get those damn
reservation people started calling at
midnight you're getting people from
where everywhere all over the world all
over the country all over the world
mm-hmm does that seem bizarre to you
yeah it's making kind of no sense to me
so what happened I think that I found
who I was supposed to be French is now
famous multi-course meals which change
every night and look like a supper club
an hour southwest of Bangor Maine
usually lasts three to four hours
and the night we visited the meal
included a selection of cheeses pea soup
with crab salad and smoked ricotta an
elevated wedge salad with bacon and
buttermilk cake as the main course and
frozen custard with almond brittle and
berries to finish this is sandy screams
to play when I was a kid in ice skate at
first
Erin French grew up with far different
plans I grew up here and freedom and ran
away with big dreams of becoming a
doctor didn't work out I became pregnant
unexpectedly and in college in college
yet dropped out which was really
terrifying I was supposed to be like the
perfect child and no supposed to be a
model student and life took me in a
different direction came home as a
single mom and started working my dad's
diner again because I had those skills
I'd started working there when I was
younger and started to sort of hone my
visions of food and figure out what I
was supposed to do with my life
French got married but as the marriage
fell apart so did she
I found challenges of anxiety and
depression just through the struggles of
the marriage and while trying to you
know raise my son between alcohol and
prescription drugs I checked into rehab
because I I was dying I mean I my body
was literally falling apart I could feel
it I could feel that I wasn't gonna
survive for a time after she traveled
around Maine and cooked out of an old
Airstream trailer she opened this lost
kitchen in freedom in 2014 in a
hydropower grist mill there is one room
with about 40 seats wasters cucumber and
dill there's a little bit of trout roe
on the top it's not just about the food
it's about the way that we make people
feeling there
the only way I know how to serve meals
and to create a space is to make it feel
like it's it's my home I think people
are starving to feel loved and to feel
cared for really well and that's what we
do when they come here so he's still
pretty important though always this has
to be how would you classify your your
cooking you know it's very simple its
ingredient focused I never write a menu
and try to confuse you with words I just
tell you what the ingredients are
because that's those are the real stars
and I feel like it's my job not to
manipulate them and not to overdo them
but just to make them they're the best
version of whatever those ingredients
are old school is a term that gets used
to my it's it becomes a cliche but
you're old school I think so all our
reservations are done by pencil and
paper we just got a website a few months
ago and it's always been really simple I
look at the world in kind of a simple
way the lost kitchen is not on open
table you know if I did that it would
take away someone's job here who's
making a living you know being here in
this community we've thought about that
a lot of people they think they have a
lot of ideas of how I should do things
what else did they say oh it should be
open more days should be open for
breakfast I should be open for lunch
dinner go longer in the year should
charge more but you know with this
attention it's gonna get there's gonna
be even more people saying this is how
you should do things that's terrifying
for now the lost kitchen is mostly a
family affair sometimes French gets her
son to pitch in
but it's her mom who really helps keep
the place humming helping in the dining
room and the wine shop downstairs her
dad the one who taught her cooking
basics all those years ago sold his
diner in 2006 my dad didn't understand
why I was trying why was I trying to
make it my own
why couldn't I just make it the way that
he taught me to make it make it this way
you can make money making clam rolls
this way let's make a burger make a
burger just make it yeah why do you he
didn't understand that and he's like why
are you doing this
people don't care they just want to be
fed
take their money and like move on did he
ever understand that no but I think he's
getting it right now for CBS this
morning Saturday
I'm Jeff Glor cheers and freedom I love
what she's done there yeah compelling
story compelling food I want a
reservation yeah I wish she was here it
looks so good but great story yeah